I was the first person to paddleboard
the length of England and then I was the
first female to paddleboard across the
English Channel being on the water helps
me restore my health and now I feel like
I want to give something back and
restore the health of the waterways
because they need it
paddle boarding was my way to tackle the
plastic pollution
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
my name is Uzi Karl I'm an adventurer
environmentalist and paddleboarder I
started paddleboarding purely as a way
of getting fit again after I was
diagnosed with cancer the first time I
put my paddle in the water it was like
meditation it was this really calming
serene experience and then all of a
sudden I'm on the water and I'm seeing
plastic everywhere on all the journeys
I've done bottles are by far the most
common thing I found I think I've
probably picked up thousands of these
you see how big and how immediate and
close the problem is eighty percent of
marine debris starts in land so
effectively from our waterways before it
flows out into the oceans for me it was
always about using adventure and paddle
boarding as a way to get people thinking
and talking about plastic pollution I
decided to paddleboard the length of
England from its most southerly point to
its most northerly point through the
connected waterways network
I started in Godalming in Surrey and I
paddled 400 miles to Kendal in the Lake
District it took 22 days to complete and
I photographed and logged every single
piece of plastic that I encountered on
that route I took over 3,000 photographs
thousands and thousands of pieces what I
loved was a crazy amount and that's not
even a fraction of it my next adventure
was paddle boarding from England to
France so it was about 24 miles I
crossed on the English Channel and take
water samples every fourth mile to
analyse microplastics
and if you look closely
[Music]
you can find if tiny pieces of
microplastics where it looks like
styrofoam has just broken down and all
that never goes away and that's when it
gets really dangerous because that's
where marine life confuses this for food
and they eat it you see it all over this
Saturday we're going out in North London
and we're doing a big cleanup there with
the community
welcome to plastic Patrol and then we'll
just get out on the water and spend a
couple of hours just paddling around and
looking for littering and putting it in
the buckets that we have in the front of
the board's over the last few years of
plastic Patrol we've collected 189 ton
bags of plastic waste and removed them
from our waterways and I look at every
single one like a victory you're seeing
the very best and the very worst of
humanity the worst is represented by all
of the plastic and the sheer volume of
plastic but you're there clearing up and
the best is the people trying to fix
that I feel more proud of that than I do
with paddle boarding a distance
[Music]
you